After two movies, a Christmas special,
and a bunch of other MCU appearances,
there's plenty of backstory for fans to
know before going in to see "Guardians
of the Galaxy Vol. 3." If something left you
wondering what you missed, here's what to know.
Warning: Spoilers ahead!
Between the events of "Guardians of the Galaxy
Vol. 2" and "Vol. 3," the ever-growing and
changing team has done plenty in other
MCU stories. They were near the center
of the action in "Avengers: Infinity War''
and "Avengers: Endgame," and they appeared
briefly at the beginning of "Thor: Love
and Thunder." The average MCU fan likely
kept up with those films and the important
plot and character developments therein,
but what's less certain is that everyone who
bought a ticket for "Vol. 3" will have seen "The
Guardians of the Galaxy Holiday Special," which
started streaming on Disney+ in November 2022.
The 42-minute special, which was in
essence an extended Kevin Bacon joke,
contains two critical pieces of
information in advance of the
third cinematic installment. For one, Mantis
reveals that she's Peter Quill's half-sister.
"Mantis, that's the greatest
Christmas gift I could ever get."
Also, sometime prior to the events of the holiday
special, the Guardians took Knowhere off of the
Collector's hands. In the first movie, the
inhabited head of a deceased celestial is
described as a lawless place of ill-repute
where one should watch their wallet. Later,
Thanos all but destroys Knowhere in
his effort to claim the Reality Stone.
During the holiday special and at the start of
"Vol. 3," the Guardians of the Galaxy' spend their
days guarding and rebuilding Knowhere, which has
become a refuge of sorts. That they're creating
their own utopian society for broken people in
a broken place is in keeping with the movie's
themes, especially when compared to the High
Evolutionary's disturbing concept of utopia.
The MCU's timeline has gotten increasingly
convoluted, especially in the post-blip era,
despite the fact that most of the franchise's
stories are told in a pretty straightforward
way. "Vol. 3" relies more than usual on
a framing device that flashes back and
forth between Rocket's youth as a captive
of the High Evolutionary and his present,
in which he's fighting for his life. This
structure definitely tugs at the heartstrings,
and the story is well-told enough to follow,
but exactly when everything is happening
and for how long is less clear.
There are visual markers that let us know some
time has passed. We first see Rocket as a kit,
then a juvenile. The High Evolutionary has
only one tiny silver device on his face as
opposed to an entire apparatus stretching
it taut. Viewers first saw Rocket in the
MCU's version of 2014, when the first
"Guardians" movie took place. "Vol. 3"
takes place after the holiday special,
which is set around Christmas of 2025.
Raccoons mature over one to two years, so
we can guess that Rocket is at least 13,
but he's probably much older. He brags that
he's escaped prison on 22 separate occasions,
which wouldn't happen overnight.
Real raccoons can live to about 16,
but his genetic and cybernetic enhancements have
almost certainly given him a longer lifespan.
As "Vol. 3" begins, Peter Quill is still reeling
from the loss of the Gamora he loved. Nebula
is doing her best to support him through his
grief, which is why she fails to mention that
the version of her sister who is now in the MCU
is her contact within the Ravagers. Whether this
Gamora is Peter's Gamora is played for light
humor and heartbreaking drama in "Vol. 3." But
it can also leave some fans who don't recall the
convoluted way we got here scratching their heads.
A great many of Marvel's Phase 3, 4, and 5
arcs have to do with alternate timelines,
universes, realms, or dimensions. Doctor
Strange, for example, met the Illuminati,
a group of supers from universe 838. This
Gamora isn't from an alternate universe, per se,
but she's not from Star-Lord's timeline. The
Gamora that loved Peter was thrown from a cliff on
Vormir during "Infinity War" so that Thanos could
obtain the Soul Stone. She's definitely dead.
"Tell me you didn't do it!"
"I had to."
"Endgame" created a new timeline branch, and
with it, a divergent Gamora with unique life
experiences and personality traits. Biologically,
she's the same being he fell in love with, but she
has totally different memories. While some comics
stories would refer to this alternate timeline as
a different universe, that doesn't seem to be the
case here. The MCU is often purposefully vague
about these distinctions, though, so as to keep
as many story possibilities as open as possible.
The gold hued race known as the Sovereign
is introduced near the beginning of "Vol.
2" when Star-Lord and company are hired to
protect their uber valuable Anulax batteries.
They're successful, which wins them the esteem
of the Sovereign, a notoriously haughty people.
Rocket destroys any good will the Guardians have
with the Sovereign almost immediately, though,
when he pockets a few Anulax batteries
in addition to their payment: Nebula.
"Vol. 2" ends with five post-credits scenes;
the third shows that High Priestess Ayesha has
something cooking -- a next-gen birthing pod.
She says she's designed "him" to destroy the
Guardians after they wronged and embarrassed
her. She adds that she'll call him Adam,
which fans correctly took to mean that
Adam Warlock's arrival was imminent.
"Vol. 3" gives Adam's backstory, as well as
the rest of the Sovereign, a tweak. The High
Evolutionary brought them into existence as
one of his experiments aimed at creating a
perfect race. Though "Vol. 2" makes it seem like
Adam was Ayesha's idea, she complains that the
High Evolutionary took him out of his cocoon too
early. This retcon doesn't come out of nowhere.
"That, my child, is the
next step in our evolution."
And it's worth noting that, while
the Sovereign are an MCU invention,
the High Evolutionary, Ayesha, and
Adam Warlock are longstanding Marvel
Comics characters who definitely matter in
each other's stories. Totally unremarked
upon in "Vol. 3" is the gem beset in Adam's
forehead. Canonically, it's the Soul Stone.
Like Marvel Comics, the MCU is loaded with
unusual celestial bodies. "Vol. 1" had the
floating decapitated head that is Knowhere, and
"Vol. 2" boasted Ego the Living Planet. Now,
"Vol. 3" presents a cosmic mass unlike anything
we've ever seen before. The Orgoscope is an
organic, bioengineered entity grown, owned,
and operated by the High Evolutionary and his
public-facing company, OrgoCorp. It's literally a
planet-sized hunk of tissue that houses OrgoCorp's
headquarters, where the company's daily operations
take place and where proprietary information,
like, say, Rocket's file, is kept secure.
That sensitive intellectual property is
guarded by OrgoSentries, one of whom is Nathan
Fillion's frustrated foreman, Master Karja.
Less weird but less well-explained is OrgoCorp
itself. "Vol. 3" only devotes a line or two
to the idea that the High Evolutionary is
the nefarious CEO of a shady conglomerate.
OrgoCorp seems to be offering naturally derived
body modifications to consumers throughout the
universe. There's an element of greenwashing to it
all, though, since we know the High Evolutionary
is also experimenting with cybernetics and has
a terrifyingly warped moral compass. OrgoCorp's
less controversial work covers for and pays
for the High Evolutionary's real passion:
callously creating and destroying
life until it fits his ideals.
It took 26 movies for two characters
to get intimate on screen in the MCU,
and even then, what was advertised as
a steamy Marvel first turned out to
be rather underwhelming. The most enduring
romance was between a witch and an android.
Second place probably goes to Peter Quill
and Gamora, and we only got a few minutes'
worth of their relationship at the very end
of "Vol. 2" and in "Avengers: Infinity War."
Fans likely went into "Vol. 3" wondering
whether the MCU might engineer a way for
Star-Lord and alternate timeline
Gamora to find love, but instead,
director James Gunn took this potential subplot in
what seems to be an entirely unexpected direction.
If you're looking for it, there's major romantic
tension between Star-Lord and Nebula throughout
"Vol. 3." Gamora herself picks up on it, after
which there's a moment when Quill seems to realize
he does find Nebula attractive. Nebula is, of
course, hard-shelled and combative as ever.
"Knock it off!"
"What? I just never noticed
how black your eyes were."
But her empathetic attitude toward him early
on combined with the closure Peter gets when
he says goodbye to Gamora leads us to
wonder: are we supposed to be shipping
Star-Lord and Nebula now? "Vol. 3" is
ambiguous enough to support the idea.
When Drax, Mantis, and Nebula get stuck on
the High Evolutionary's pyramid-shaped vessel,
they discover an onboard prison full of
fair-haired children. Mantis and Nebula struggle
to communicate with the scared kids, but Drax,
who comforts them by badly imitating a monkey,
eventually reveals that he speaks their
language. After Peter manages to save Rocket,
the Guardians' mission becomes rescuing
the innocents trapped on that ship.
The film never provides the name of their
race or a planet from which they might hail,
but two clues help to fill in the blanks. In
one, the High Evolutionary watches a blonde
girl run circles in a human-sized
hamster wheel. He's annoyed that,
while he's been able to engineer negative
qualities out of her, he hasn't been able
to replicate Rocket's superior intellect.
Since the High Evolutionary's methods seem
to be capturing specimens and rapidly evolving
them or breeding them through birthing pods,
these children are basically the High
Evolutionary's latest guinea pigs.
In the mid-credits stinger, the girl who
was jogging around the hamster wheel has
joined the new iteration of the Guardians
led by Rocket Raccoon. The others refer to
her as Phyla. This is almost definitely Marvel
Comics' Phyla Vell, a genetically engineered
super-humanoid and the daughter of Mar-Vell, who
does eventually join the Guardians of the Galaxy.
Superhero movies usually have over-the-top
fights that would absolutely prove fatal
to normal people, but "Vol. 3" takes this idea
to the extreme. Because it's advertised as the
finale of the "Guardians" trilogy, and because the
trailers and press tour seemed to foreshadow some
tissue-worthy tragedy, most fans fully expected
a fan-favorite protagonist would die. Instead,
"Vol. 3" contains multiple fake-out deaths,
but no main character kicks the bucket.
"Are you ready? For one last ride?"
Rocket's near-death experience is not only
plausible, but it also serves as the catalyst
for the whole plot. Drax takes two deadly
blasts to the chest but manages to recover,
seemingly thanks to the same med
packs that wouldn't work on Rocket.
But Groot is decapitated in a duel with Adam
Warlock on Knowhere, after which the Sovereign
takes Nebula's comically-large energy blade to
the chest and collapses, lifeless. And Quill
succumbs to the elements in space. How did they
live through that? It's easy enough to explain
with Groot. He has sped-up regenerative powers,
especially as they pertain to his limbs. Since
he wasn't completely destroyed, he simply had to
regrow the plant matter that makes up his body,
and he remained the same Groot, which wasn't the
case after "Vol. 1." The MCU's Adam Warlock has
superior durability and healing. In the comics, he
can be killed but can't actually die. At the end
of the movie, he imparts this ability to Peter,
who really was a goner, to bring him back to life.
"Vol. 3" was meant to be the capstone
to these superheroes' shared story,
and based on all the tearful goodbyes in
the film's final moments, it probably is,
at least as a group. Gamora
returns to the Ravagers,
and her smile makes it clear that's where she
belongs. Mantis goes off to find herself. And
Drax adopts the children that had been the
captive subjects of the High Evolutionary.
The actors who play those characters, Zoe
Saldana, Pom Klementieff, and Dave Bautista,
have indicated they're unlikely to return to
the MCU. But the mid-credits stinger teases
a new Guardians team moving forward, led by
Rocket, and made up of Groot, Cosmo, Kraglin,
Adam Warlock, and Phyla. Whether we ever actually
see this team in action is yet to be determined,
but at least in fans' imaginations,
they're out there guarding the galaxy.
For his part, Peter Quill returns to
Earth to reconcile with his grandfather,
Jason. Curiously, there's a
tacked-on title card that reads,
"The Legendary Star-Lord will return."
That seems to indicate Chris Pratt will
be reprising the role. With Gunn having
migrated to DC, the future of the "Guardians"
franchise is up in the air. But Star-Lord
is a marquee MCU character and Pratt is
a bankable star. Since he's back on his
home planet, it's possible we'll see him
again in a standalone film or in a cameo
in another hero's film, but it's just as
possible that he'll re-take to space to
play a part in the "Avengers" movies
slated to premiere in 2025 and 2026.